buckle up welcome to Hannity thank you
for being with us we have multiple major
developments to bring you including
proof that commis deep state cabal spied
on the Trump campaign we have tonight
breaking news an admission from the
Ukrainian Embassy in fact the DNC did
try to collude with their government
during the 2016 election we actually
have evidence we're going to show you
how the Democratic Party is unravelling
right before your eyes lawmakers
presidential candidates alike literally
melting down because they're Russia
Russia Russia collusion fantasy it's
over anything from here on is just noise
nothing more noise the witch hunt is
done Muller has gone home no collusion
no obstruction they lost they lied they
conspired they sent out conspiracy
theories and hoaxes and now the
boomerang of Justice is in full motion
we start tonight a breaking report from
the New York Times which might have
actually gotten something straight for a
change amazing they even said Wow the
dossier might actually be Russian
disinformation to influence the 2016
election the one Hillary paid for but
according to the paper their news
tonight deep state spying against the
Trump campaign did occur a little late
but in a big way the headline reads
quote FBI sent investigator posing as
assistant to meet with Trump aide in
2016 the article details a London
meeting between a female FBI
investigator working undercover a
Cambridge professor and a foreign policy
expert named Stefan Halper he we've
talked a lot about this and Trump
campaign adviser George papadopolis he
spent two weeks in jail the meetup
meetup was supposed to be a forum policy
strategy session the undercover
investigator well set up the meeting
halper was working as a secret FBI
informant and the pair both worked in
unison to spy on Papadopoulos to set the
Trump campaign up quote the conversation
at a London bar in September 2016 took a
strange turn when the woman sitting
across from George papadopolis a state
direct question was the Trump campaign
working with Russia
keep in mind helper was also set up
multiple meetings with Trump campaign
aide Carter page and Sam Clovis and who
was being wiretapped another way they
spied on the Trump campaign by the FBI
after the FBI director Comey and others
obtained that FISA warrant using Hillary
Clinton's opposition research with the
New York Times is now suggesting could
be Russian disinformation the phony
unverified dossier the dirty Russian
dossier Wow it's all beginning to come
into focus as I've been predicting none
of these spying sessions yielded any
evidence of Trump Russia collusion
because there was no collusion but
without a doubt spying the Attorney
General was right did occur in the
height of a presidential election under
the Biden Obama administration's watch
against an opposition party candidate
who knew what when we will get those
answers eventually tonight Democrats
they are pretty detached from reality as
I said anything from here on in it's
noise they can't handle they couldn't
handle the election loss they can't
handle no collusion no obstruction but
it's over but watch him anyway
in the entirety of your previous career
in the Department of Justice including
as Attorney General
have you ever referred to authorized
Department investigative activities
officially or publicly as spying I'm not
asking for private conversations I'm not
going to have juror the use of the word
spying I think you know my first job was
in CIA and I don't think the word spying
has any pejorative connotation at all to
meet us to me the question is always
whether or not it's authorized and
adequately predicated spying
I think spying is a good English word
that in fact doesn't have synonyms
because it is the broadest word
incorporating really all forms of covert
intelligence collection so I'm not gonna
back off the word spying by the way
thank God for the
great intelligence officers that serve
We the People
there's protecting us every day the 99%
thank God for the premier law
enforcement agency in the entire world
the FBI the 99% tonight though we know
that the deep state aggressively spied
on the Trump campaign during and after
the election that's the biggest abuse of
power that's what we gotta solve and if
we don't get to the bottom of it we lose
the country no sign that the Clinton
campaign faced any similar scrutiny even
though as it turns out well there was a
massive amount of evidence that Clinton
and the DNC were the ones pay close
attention trying to collude with foreign
governments don't take it from me just
look at what the Ukrainian embassy
confirmed to the hills John Solomon who
will join us in a minute
bombshell new report from him details
the government of Ukraine is accusing a
DNC contractor named Alexandra shallow
Saluja of attempting to conclude with
their government saying that she quote
sought information from the Ukrainian
government on Paul Manafort dealings
inside the country in the hopes of
forcing the issue before Congress
according to the ambassador's office
chalupa also quote tried to arrange for
the Ukrainian president to comment on
mana for its Russian ties on a u.s.
visit during the 2016 campaign evidence
this comes after Ukrainian court found
that high-ranking officials inside its
government sought to help Hillary
Clinton win the election and admission
from Bruce or that a Ukrainian lawmaker
was feeding phony anti-trump dirt to
Fuzion GPS the firm that well yeah Bruce
hores wife Nelly worked for the firm
responsible for the bought and paid for
Russian lies to influence the 2016
election might have been Russian
disinformation according to the New York
Times